me semble que les gaffes à son arrivée à
une taille en fait et à une puissance
qui font d'elle en fait non plus des
entreprises mais maintenant des néo
états c'est-à-dire d'aider des
organismes que nous ne connaissons pas a
certes sous droit privé mais qui
aujourd'hui une influence politique
économique on a été même jusqu'à avec
facebook imaginer une monnaie
indépendante
bon finalement ça n'aide pas tu toujours
pas fait mais enfin on verra de quoi
l'avenir sera fait et effectivement il
ya un vrai sujet même vis-à-vis des
américains
ses gaffes à ces grandes entreprises du
numérique échappe clairement au contrôle
démocratique qui serait légitime d'avoir
pour c'est pour ces entreprises du côté
des baies à thé xx du côté chinois c'est
évidemment différent puisque on voit que
des contrôles beaucoup plus forts de de
l'état et c'est évidemment un régime que
qu'on souhaite absolument pas pour nos
territoires et on peut - on se retrouve
moins dans ce modèle bien entendu ce
qu'on peut dire en tout cas nous les
européens c'est que cette souveraineté
elle nous échappe totalement
moi c'est vrai que je vous écoute et
avec beaucoup beaucoup d'attention à ce
point vous avez évoqué un sujet très
important c'est cet aspect intimement
politique de vision politique qui manque
cruellement à nos décideurs européens
aujourd'hui
moi je pense qu'effectivement il faut
que nous réussissions à construire une
puissance en europe par seulement en
france en allemagne en espagne et c'est
à m'aimer mais véritablement une
politique de souveraineté numérique
mais comme il est difficile de se dire
on a déjà loupé les premières étapes moi
je crois que c'est ça le un des sujets
qui nous empêche d'avoir cette cette
politique numérique aujourd'hui on se
dit sans cesse on va être les meilleurs
sur l'intelligence artificielle
puis après on se dit on va être les
meilleurs sur la blogo chain depuis
maintenant on s'est dit on va être les
meilleurs sur l'info sur le cantique
en réalité je pense que tout ça manque
de vision long terme
alors est-ce que c'est dû au fait que
les mandats sont extrêmement courts
maintenant auprès de nos dirigeants
peut-être un mais ce qu'il faudrait
c'est à mon sens se dire que il faut
arrêter d'essayer de rattraper le retard
il faut essayer de construire
[Musique]